I was with a bank for 29 years I thought
I was I was a star but I got to a point
where I just noticed I was blocked and I
wasn't going higher and I'm like okay
this is a time to step back and get
additional skills additional knowledge
the new ways of doing things
the first school that I looked at was
Stanford and when I saw the content of
the program I said this is exactly what
I need the new the strategy the new ways
of doing things I was certain this was
the program I was putting it all
together to take me to the next level
then I got this big opportunity to work
for UBS there are great learnings that
have been able to apply in my new
workplace I'm just so confident to shift
from this topic to that topic whether
it's finance whether is customer
experience whether it's managing change
I find that what I learned is beginning
to impact how I am doing what I'm doing
on my new bank my new rope and I'm
getting more success because I have
learned so much from the leap program
what I found most fascinating was that a
virtual program doesn't feel like it's
virtual
the a virtual program is more effective
than any other face-to-face program that
I've done you actually don't get to feel
that you are doing this long distance my
colleagues on the job once they know
that ie I have my exact education with
Stanford they take another look at me
and like the leap program that is an
understatement I love it I love it the
leap program is a once-in-a-lifetime
opportunity
[Music]